[Music]
for six months my team and I have
traveled all over Britain
tasting considering and arguing over the
great restaurants you nominated I'd put
all these contenders through a series of
grueling pressure tests dancing that and
I've been blown away by their drive
determination and passion to reach the
final let's go and now it's the final
showdown just two restaurants remain
incredible Indian cooking combining
passion and great skill Bradford's
amazing pressure art and my best Italian
avant-garde casimir from Bristol what a
fight this is gonna be on the one hand
I've got two very talented young guys
cooking ultra-modern
Italian food like no other restaurant
anywhere in England today on the other
hand I've got this tiny Indian
restaurant headed up with the mother and
daughter-in-law that quite honestly are
cooking some of the most delicious
vegetarian food I've ever tasted
anywhere in the world this for me is
gonna be one of the most difficult
choices I've ever made
having made it this far both restaurants
think they have what it takes to win
this competition we want to win you know
there's no doubt by every wanna win
we're going there to hopefully be chrome
Ramsay's best restaurant we can do it
you know I mean we really seriously
bloody do it company yeah absolutely
kazimierz journey to this point has been
far from easy their avant-garde take
early Italian food is bold and delicious
really good presentation unique but
sometimes it's too experimental and
doesn't always hit the mark in the
semi-final these ambitious young Chefs
showed me to have the balls to strip
back the excessive frills
and become worthy finalists well done
you can smoke breakfast bechard have
been a surprise of this competition and
now this humble restaurant has tasted
success they're hungry to win this is
the tough wake of competition I tell you
work hard and leave to God
we will fight so much and we want to win
we want to win it will be biggest day in
my whole life they're small
unpretentious restaurant serves
fantastic Gujarati cuisine with no heirs
or graces delicious one mouthful of that
I feel like I'm back in Mumbai whatever
I cook it from my heart I love cooking
I sent in the coach load of dinars but
not everyone was happy to be in a
vegetarian restaurant hammer confirmed
carnival anything without me isn't
really classed as a meal but we all left
convert it amazing presentation and then
the test itself I think will try and
come here here is the exquisite food and
sheer determination of manal and kal she
booked them their place in the final
it's Bashar everything has been building
to this moment
one final grueling test which will help
me choose my best restaurants
my finalists are traveling to Petrus my
new central London restaurants these
luxurious surroundings will be the
battlefield for the biggest day of their
cooking careers it's here they'll fight
it out for the title of my best
restaurant
[Music]
absolutely
winning this will be for everyone my
parents my family my customer as well
nobody sunk in so now that you know this
is not a final one this is what we need
to do it's going up see the perfect I'm
at number four don't sleep reason after
all these years of putting in hard work
doing something what's really different
and people not necessarily agreeing with
it I'm following us if this is gonna
prove a lot of people rolling I believe
my god help me so definitely me work
hard be coming to work hard and hard and
hat and I can see what hard-working pay
Wow effective good morning this is it
big day today you are in control of your
destiny
castamere versus prasad two unique
restaurants go head to head in the final
good luck to both and may the best
restaurant win thank you very much thank
you this is the first time each
restaurant has met and now they're about
to be pitched head-to-head across my
kitchen Shawn Kenny did and well so we
need to work hard
both restaurant star prep and I'm
expecting nothing less than perfection
each team must produce a stunning
three-course menu that sums up what's
best about their restaurant encapsulate
s' their love of food and demonstrates
their passion for cooking if we get it
right you simply just be bliss and
people will just enjoy it and save John
Thomases lovely dish
[Music]
Bobby and his brother mayor will be
running service for Prashad whilst mum
and dad team Packer and Susan will be
running front of house for the castamere
boys we know their food is gonna come
fantastically good
so let's match their food with a service
I've packed the dining room with some of
the brilliant restaurant teams that have
taken part in this competition so both
food and service will be under extreme
scrutiny we're gonna give our heart on a
plate in passion in love and dignity
every single thing counts today
and I've got one more surprise for the
restaurants my finalists will also be
cooking for one of Britain's best chefs
Angela harlot and my two secret diners
there's no secret footage yes she'll be
cooking alive in front of them sat on
the chef's table and a big tasting
scrutinizing dissecting and really get
into grips with what you think is your
best menu so far excited this is it make
your counts do not send anything that's
less than 1% perfect good luck thanks
Gordon we wrote me in one minute from
now yeah good luck I'll figure guys yes
all the best first up the starters away
now three star risotto true to form
John ray and Peter are pushing the
boundaries with an experimental dish at
their Bristol restaurant they're known
for their avant-garde take on Italian
cuisine still in their twenties these
two young chefs are fayliss in their
approach to cooking they retain the
flavors and spirit of Italian food but
give it the unique stamp we think in our
own net waterways and our own little
bubble what sometimes to come across is
being young and naive but I think it
also helps create what we are that's
something different
they're start for the final is risotto
with mushrooms and rosemary but
naturally it has a twist we're gonna use
new potatoes to create little grains of
rice that going to give you that
impression in the mouth of your eating
rice but instead y'all at me they want
potato
this dish is typical of casa mia with
clever unusual and packed full of flavor
it'd be a lot easier just to get the
rice I think but we will take it so
that's it
what many chefs will have the time or
even patience of it first
the potatoes are Laporte's they cut into
individual shaped grains of rice next
peter and john r a finely chopped garlic
and Schloss with a precision of surgeons
it's all about speed sometimes about
perfection and getting it right followed
by button mushrooms and porcini they're
gonna have a real depth of flavor to
them a lot more than the fresh mushroom
itself it's about just playing around
protections and referrals
just like a traditional risotto they
start by sweating the slots off in olive
oil
we don't want to bring any of
caramelized flavors keep it very clean
very pure next they had the garlic and
porcini so that I start getting that
background flavor into the dish pouring
the white wine and reduce its liking
like Weaver pudding kind of really vice
and then go with our chicken stock and
what chicken stock is gonna do is just
reduce further out of starch from the
potato so you're gonna start to get the
creaminess then they add mushrooms
chopped rosemary grated Parmesan -
screams Italy definitely is just
fantastic
butter for richness and to give it a
delicate onion note chopped chives we
look at ourselves sometimes it as
artists we don't just assume that we're
chefs what we do is just replicate
masterpieces of work again and again and
again finally this mouth-watering
masterpiece is finished with rosemary
infused oil flavors are plans made a
sous more [ __ ] the experimental nature
of the boys cooking means the requires
extraordinary attention to detail and
this is really slowing them down I just
need some bigger pants it's a very small
now you say to me now I so I said you've
gotta go organize guys the best fresh
I'm not the most disorganized no to make
matters worse they aren't working
together properly either as one cooks
the first order the other should be
getting the next ready
how long for that first chef table
please one minute chef thank you oh you
starting to 6 behind it is anyone
starting I'm just saying it is anyone
starts yes okay good if I boast about
the teamwork it has to deliver the
teamwork just and in John ray watching
you and you watching dawn right let's go
get involved to get the guys there's
yeah it's a really massive pressure but
hopefully we're just gonna cook what we
always cook up on the heart and if it's
gonna be purpose
well it won't be if they don't start
working together customers are waiting
and Casimir haven't served a single dish
we've said eight minutes where are now
in 12 minutes how long for the first
risotto you have two minutes two minutes
yes thank you let's go so easy not the
servant well you get the next one ready
come on bye Pete look at me please
can you look at me I got it up no come
here both your minute look so can he not
serve that while you get the next one
ready yes I do that [ __ ] all the guys
please finally the risotto leads the
kitchen hydrogen a system now yes yes
sorry I know it's hard getting out the
traps I appreciate that I need a [ __ ]
system working otherwise we're going to
sink yes yes sink sink sink
although the boys are sending out food
slowly their parents are doing their
best to be charming so this is a new
potato risotto with wild mushrooms and
rosemary oil so she's playing with mines
with different textures but first
restaurant Casimir defeated on the way
to the final was the fantastic Italian
minuta from London
what will head chef Santino think of
this data they're pushing the boundaries
further they're taking what results
always and saying they say the right
side replace with potato I mean who the
hell would do that I mean but it really
did work so it's very clever
[Music]
qasimi's food is going down well but the
boys are boring he disorganized that was
[ __ ] let me tell you why you can't
stand there where your head in a pan and
then run up the hot plate and start
serving food and you can't stand there
my man and look around him you've got to
work together yes pop up sander was
amazing
yes roll off the road amazing but there
seems to be no system here today got to
get a system come on made time to find
out what my experts made of Casimir
starter very real flavorful it's
delicious would that taste better than a
normal rock toad done with a boar oh
right what we said what is the point
there's no point in having to do
something different they're always
pushing it you're inventing things
that's quite fun that's it work yes or
no I love it
did it work yes yes it worked for the
starter Posada making chat delicious
take on a traditional gujarati street
food pressure on small 22 seat Indian
restaurant in Bradford has been at the
heart of the local community for 18
years over time they've transformed
humble vegetarian dishes from Gujarat in
Northwest India into something truly
magical when I'm making any food I'm so
happy I put my positive thinking and my
love so I'm making not for the business
I'm making like my family chance the
Poplar Street dish but it isn't easy to
prepare this recipe has layer upon layer
of wonderful flavors look simple and
sound simple but a lot of going on three
sauces boiling potatoes boiling
chickpeas crying pasties making chili
sauce making noodles we making our own
samosas it's complicated first me now
prepares a rich tamarind sauce by
boiling tamarind dates and jaggery and
unrefined cane sugar sour is a tamarind
and sweet we were going to put some
dates so right balance sweet and sour
next Kelsey slices samosa pastry leaves
into squares and deep fries by brown
color very crispy
for the noodles manal blends gram flour
with sunflower oil it's like soft wood
if it's not smooth Dennis knodel be
funky
meanwhile counties on to the next source
blending garlic chilli powder salt and
lemon juice yeah like really want things
hot then the samosas
first they 5p and add turmeric coriander
and garam masala a special blend of
spices the masala is my own garam masala
I lost it and then I grind it myself
that's right there everything so tasty
finally potatoes are boiled diced and
turned into the mix the last process is
a delicate one filling the samosa pastry
it's cool if if something goes wrong
it's difficult vamos fazer you know is a
very tricky very tricky the balance of
flavors and textures in this dish are
pitch-perfect
sweet sour spicy crunchy and soft the
way that prasad bring vegetarian food to
life is a revelation
I am pondered for some real winner
four solid five comes away Table one yes
thank you okay now I want to hear you
just disintegrate me now I want to yeah
yeah mommy
leaving that five have gone I need six
now please thank you
yep in contrast the Casimir boys Manila
and Kelsey are showing fantastic
teamwork from the word go how are you
fine you do knows where other to please
me now yeah yeah good okay good thank
you Malaya and Kelsey are really hitting
their stride
the organization is spot on but they
need to watch their presentation every
time yeah I can't wipe your plate
I cannot wipe your place yeah okay go
please that's table - Bobbi is integral
to the success of Rashard his service
throughout the competition has been
charismatic professional and
knowledgeable thank you yeah we try to
use a traditional street dish so
basically the hot with the cold sweet
with the spicy just to kind of ignite
all your flavors all the way through the
mail it's also playing his part in the
kitchen encouraging me now and giving a
customer feedback me know yeah table
number three compliments to the chef the
starters are amazing thank you keep
coming thank you but just when it's all
going so right dishes get sent to the
wrong table
and Bobby's two starters short
the feminist artists have been mated to
a ready table four stars which is table
number five I take two of these
incomplete that's not a mistake like
this can throw a kitchen into chaos if
they're not clear they come back down
with a tray okay and they tell me and I
rectify it again okay they cannot go to
a different [ __ ] table
so when I send two Chataway on seven and
two way in Table eight it's got to go
there
Manila doesn't miss the beat she just
deals with the problem smoothly and
efficiently I cannot have this mistake
starting with a main course okay let's
go I need two more got the other ten
enough love it
we've rectified them how long for the
chunk five minutes let's go I've got two
table one please let's go nice a steady
let's go oh wait now two chefs in the
first round of the competition Prashad
came up against another exceptional
Indian the brilliant from London
what will front of house manager Dibner
think of their chat now to hear what my
experts made a push on starter I quite
like the adventurous task of trying to
put the hot samosa inside the garnish
the joy of pressured is that they are
very comfortable in their own boundaries
and you know we meet some fantastic food
up and breakfast
okay go please good lay down well done
well done well done well done
starters finished I need to taste both
dishes showers chat nice well that he
have nice sweet tamarind flavor I like
the hot samosa running through but it's
got that balance between the sweet
savory on the heat there as well very
good
risotto of new potatoes only these guys
would turn potatoes into granules of
rice
it's very rich for the CEPS you're gonna
need two or three mouthfuls of it so
it's not like a proper risotto
however wait clever if there's one
criticism on that which is a touch too
salty - very interesting starters right
now which one to prefer out of those two
what I have to say my final is casa mia
the culinary alchemist from Bristol and
Prasad the Masters of vegetarian Indian
and cuisine from Bradford are battling
it out for the title of my best
restaurant I want both these amazing
Russians to do their talent justice
tonight some expecting perfection in
their main courses it's good to be tough
now it's coming to them close living
cautious up top okay Cass the man three
stunning turbot awaits chef's table yeah
yes yeah
Prasad three stunning bindi chef table
fantastic yeah really good I guess we're
a little bit slow they need to improve
their coordination skills rather than
sort of trying to cook silently as one
tables go in the shop one working so
there's not as static in between john
ray and peter never make life easy for
themselves
at their restaurant in Bristol they're
always pushing the boundaries with their
food trying to create new exciting
flavor and texture combinations
sometimes we play to extreme but I think
that's just because it's the way we are
we will always take it a step further
and never hold back we'll always put it
up there and give it our best shot for
the main course that stay true to their
inventive spirit pairing meat with fish
when Peter first presented this to me
and I tried obviously blown away I just
works fantastically they're cooking
roast turbot with chicken wings and
roast salsify Peter starts by finishing
the fish and it isn't long before he
pulls out one of these potions now we're
gonna use something called protein glue
protein blue or transglutaminase
literally bonds Fillies together by just
sprinkling it over at all then we just
match up the Phillips from the top to
the bottom we create that kind of big
thick piece of fish then the south of
mine a vegetable from the root or the
purple sauce white flour it's very
earthy very sweetness as well almost
like a kind of sweetness of a oyster
true to casimir form all the ingredients
in this dish are cooked sous-vide in a
water bath sweet place that inside a
vacuum pack the fish takes 15 minutes
chicken wings take 12 hours and if it
good takes time I think and also we can
see a great end result then it's worth
all the time the board next to herbes
you a blend of chives chervil and
parsley is pureed finally sift and then
placing this machine that creates a
vacuum removing all the air bubbles we
use this all the time constantly there's
no more way in four days things
to the outcomes I so you see now it's
pure my criticize customary for
overusing the water bath because not all
ingredients suited so how they learned
their lesson the whole secret is just to
finish it in a pan and just let this
skin just crisp it create our
caramelized corn flavor in it
unbelievable absolutely walking it's
great news because customers are
comfortable with pan frying but it's
just one more stage in an already
complicated process
keeping is the timing of everything yeah
at the time that's not that pretty much
be screwed this is beautiful refined
cooking simplicity on the plate achieved
with technical precision and attention
to detail that pushes their you know
corner 110% and it pushes you all the
way not only does he want to be some
communication but he wants the dish it's
not that perfect obviously see tonight
we've got like people on chef say water
we've got please and the rest of the
darkness so absolutely mad experience
kazimierz main course is a complicated
dish and it will demand the kind of
teamwork they haven't shown yet the boys
are still infuriatingly slow getting
food out I need to see some form of
[ __ ] teamwork going on there's one
thing I've got with you guys is a stop
start stop start you've got to get 21st
century flow it's nice to push the boat
out we gotta get to a flow yes finally
they seem to be hitting their stride
shevelle just like ever the sauce on
there and the food looks amazing but how
has the unusual combination of chicken
and fish gone down with my diners server
works excellent with me
I think this absolutely sound to choice
that they made the turbot was perfect
the chicken wings were really good and
the satisfy brought it all together the
creaminess in the middle again it's
worried expect me because I mean
they're very clever they know what
they're doing and he was executed
let's go phew that's funny Peter but
looks fantastic guys keep it going yes
chef for work not sure what's the boys
daring dish has really impressed
upstairs their parents so say so say are
clearly feeling the strain
but on the pillar for the other lady
with banco still to go will they be able
to hold it together
I'm feel a little bit under pressure a
little bit
this is Gordon Ramsay the best
restaurant to lose your best time to
find out what my experts on the chef's
table thought of customers main course
I think elements on that plate were
fantastic from Casimir I love the voice
itself quite I'm not the way they used
to travel on the plate I thought that
was delicious and fantastic combination
did you put the whole thing together
seasoned the whole plates perfect yeah I
thought it was a good effort sounds to
be pure always delicious the roasted
sounds we show up in experience when
they're hard you know they gave it
perfectly being really reinvented
they're coming up with new dishes
specifically for this competition eyes
in contrast the Casimir Prasad have
chosen to cook a simpler main course
it's not hard because every day we
making this we so happy
what are like he said very good very
good so we happy happy
we got a confidence now they're putting
their faith in a dish that loved by the
devoted band of Bradford regulars what
we chosen the meal is a traditionally
Gujarati meal okra is very popular my
customer love the okra in the Prasad is
a fasting selling this the key to
personal success is the way they
transform traditional family recipes
with a unique balance of tastes textures
and spices in India every two days
reading okra and the dal and rice for
the main course they're cooking okra
curry said with a Gujarati dal soup rice
and writer
we now start by chopping an onion and
fry in it with fenugreek seeds and
chopped garlic then Cal she adds
turmeric red chilli powder ground
coriander and tomatoes next the okra
sometimes called lady's fingers it's a
type of green bean its sticky inside if
you dry them there before it's better if
you make press then we stick with each
other now she fries it and adds it to
the curry next the lentil soup or dal
lentil is save time because we need to
boil not ready at least 15 minutes when
the lentils are ready we're now liquid
our system and then add liquid eisah
martyrs then the prasad magic turmeric
red chilli powder jaggery and finally
coriander this is a very balanced meal
because okra it's not too spicy curry
that lentil soup it's very creamy and
rich and little bit of sweet and tangy
so flavor is balanced very well finally
me now price dried chilies and a skew
min and then returns to the dal
[Music]
I'm just checking is yeah he's done in
Indian cuisine is a not much going on in
a presentation so now I have to try with
harder F Gordon says we need penis when
we serving the complex interplay of
chase works bring me in this dish creamy
crunchy cold spicy prasad are always
trying to elevate humble vegetables to
odd cuisine for the five please what's
really impressing me today is how prasad
are trying to keep the soul of their
homeland Gujarati dishes but giving them
a facelift for my restaurants never yeah
but a service ramps up eating for shards
Kampf Assad is beginning to crack food
is being spilled and starting to get in
each other's way
[Music]
yeah away now
the Pope is back on form and holding it
together in the dining room there in the
flow now the first coming up is from
this good and it's been received what a
Prasad than enough to convince my diners
their main cause is worthy of the final
it's contemporary this morning which I
like this office is delicious but will
it be enough to impress my demanding
experts facades bindi how was that okra
the tastes were really intense very
powerful and really expertly done and
done with ease you can tell the person
that cooked that they just do it with
ease it comes you know it's very passion
and it just it's really skillful very
first very hard to get okra tasting
delicious
it was great I just think they could
have lifted everything slightly one
level up
[Music]
okay calcium in our main course it's all
gone good job great job yes
lay down get ready for dessert yes after
judging the starters
I put Prashad ahead on the night as
kazimierz main pulled it back
I kept main courses just a mere turbot
cooked water bar you all right
delicious there's elements of maturity
across this plate because they're
listening they're using the techniques
their kin to with their slow cooking
water bath but they're bringing in you
know the roasting of a turbot at the end
very clever for the chicken the turbot
work and its harmony there really good
result
Wow delicious want more aquas delicious
a little crunch it really is a vibrant
and a nice blend of spices really nice
what they have done across this main
course is that refined it they've really
brought Gujarati to Knightsbridge both
teams have really taken onboard my
constructive prison and today delivered
two fantastic main courses which one
would have prefer right now both of them
the dessert will be the decider both
teams have to keep their nerve and cook
the dish of their lives all right guys
let's call chef me now Cousy last course
keep it going yes okay end on a high yes
from their small deli attached to the
restaurant in Bradford Prashad serve a
huge range of deliciously sweet Indian
dessert which calcium are now are
attempting to modernize for their final
dish they hope will win them this
competition we making homemade Indian
sweet this sweets is a delicate same
time is a rich also Gordon will
definitely like it he liked my food so
I'm sure he liked this one also all
three of the traditional Indian desserts
use a combination of key flour and sugar
either refined white or the Indians
favorite jaggery an unrefined sugar that
is extremely sweet but extremely popular
in Indian desserts sesame seed and
they're gonna get together very well
ones rolled with sesame seeds
another is flattened spiced with
cardamom then finished with pistachios
and almonds and the third and final
sweets is a simple blend of sesame seeds
and jaggery that is cut into squares and
the finished dish will be washed down
with sweetened ginger tea in India
people how they think that the half milk
half water boiling or put some ginger
and sugar and keep boiling until it's
really good taste
I think Prasad have been clever to
create a simple dish that is easy to
plate and requires very little cooking
during service it's a nice way of
finishing a classic main course what I
like about it is quite modern and
they've sort of taking a leaf out of
kazimierz book there but well they're
doing that with Italian food I can do
that with vegetarian Indian food clever
they look fantastic but before I make my
own mind up I want to see what my
experts and diners think of these
modernized Indian sweets I was quite
excited why they make them look almost
like sort of little miniature petit
fours but they were just I often do
sweeping sometimes you get sugar rush
this kind of gave me a sugar bash on the
head yeah just too much very different
but then they're quite traditional
within themselves so I thought that was
a nice mixture of old and new and trying
to mixed up a bit I like the one at the
end which was the slightly card one to
me mainly because it is less sweet you
know it had a great structure to it you
know had a lovely little buttery nutty
flavor to it
I don't think they'll ever get away from
those over sweetness star but I have to
applaud them for their mobilization of a
dessert yeah I think I did a great thing
today actually flames on this only
remind me of one only love a spicy very
very
frankly what I actually bit into them
there was one sesame lib to which before
that was really nice I really like that
I don't like ginger tea at all but I
like that ginger tea wasn't to gingery
but if I must say so come here again
John raphe to end on a high please yes
yes yeah last course yeah come on make
it work yes but Casimir to beat this
that have to really pull something out
of the bag but the Panna cottas that
prepared earlier but way too thick so
now they've said they're much too solid
small but only a Panna cottas in a
moment so just get the gelatine never
white but not milk it's working for some
pine nuts package sugar and hopefully
restore faithful this is a brave move
late in the day but everything these
boys do is risky especially the rest of
the dessert that they've been perfecting
in their Bristol HQ we always twice go
out with a big bang a big wow it's gonna
be an award winning dish and it's gonna
win this got black competition the first
part is a lemon sorbet but the boys are
not using just any lemons marfa lemons
amazing we use them all the time in the
kitchen because of bloody brilliant arm
they're not as harsh as normal lemons
and they've got a fantastic aroma for us
the desserts is such an important part
but 11 will not just be used in the
sorbet the Amalfi Coast is in southern
Italy and that is where the boys want to
take the diners
we want to almost recreate alpha kou
smell that's the plan that's a little
magic plan that we've got in our head
the boys are making a lemon tea which
they'll pull over the kitchen alchemists
favorite the T is going to be infused
with zest and lemon juice that's gonna
be poured on the bottom what's gonna be
hot we're gonna pull liquid nitrogen
that's gonna flood the room oh man this
here wall Belletti brilliant it works
really well this end of the night
spectacular could steal the show if only
they'd get it on time
just send some food will you let's go
unbelievable
everything hangs on the panna cotta if
it collapses so will their dreams are
becoming Molly best restaurant Panna
cottas turned out to be perfect so I'm
really happy that accordion texture that
consistency was lovely Thank You chef
the panna cotta is perfect and now's the
moment when it should all come together
[Music]
kazimierz liquid nitrogen wizardry has
one of my experts and the diners
but is this just another casimir gimmick
[Music]
the proof of the pudding is as ever in
the eating panna cotta and how was that
I mean for me it was delicious I mean
made to test you just move it and it's
got that wobbliness to it structure
I thought the lemon with the pineapple
was absolutely brilliant and I mean I
like you I hate the gimmicky normally
but it served its purpose I love the way
they tried to get that extra element in
there so it's all the senses its smell
its didn't work though yes it did work
all the way in it enhanced it wasn't
just a gimmick when you're very
inventive I like those chefs are
sometimes it's just all invention and no
practicality has no purpose to it now
that had purpose and it had a church
come what a finale I mean it just looked
amazing for the restaurant he worked for
the dish
[Music]
for Casa Mae and Prasad has taken a
shedload of drive determination and
skill to get to the final all our
customers are happy they don't know who
their plates are empty that's why we are
released now and very lady we're going
to win definitely we are I don't know if
you won
it's too close to call again it's too
close these guys are fast so loss
tonight it's no doubt about it
we're running round like pricks
literally running around like brutes in
there but we did that this year we can
cook in the dining room thoughts now
turn to which restaurant the diners
preferred
my vote definitely because I mean I
wouldn't say overall that I preferred a
shart I really enjoy assured and my team
on the chef's table have offered their
expert analysis the starter main course
dessert was in balance that it had
finesse did it work across the three
courses gates took risks in different
ways by the time they came to the end of
their main course they're in their
rhythm they've got those knives on top
of the fact this is a master magician
what you did something missing clear
who's [ __ ] winning your can best for
sure i've listened to everyone else's
opinions now I have to decide who should
be my best restaurant but before I
choose I'm going to taste the crucial
dessert course dessert should always end
on a high Prasad they've done a little
selection of desserts says me see very
very sweet very heavy and then you sort
of wash that down with a ginger chai
it's nice
teas lovely no one really knows Indian
desserts that well so to cut them up
into almost like little sweet petit
fours they are delicious
quite nice with that sweet and savory
quite light and again you've got that
room that vibrant nice here we go
the Amalfi Hills come to Knightsbridge
all that fragrant zest
that's like lemon pulp in there over the
dry ice and really nice rich and Malfi
lemons beautiful mmm Wow someone's like
you're taking a steam bar a fragrant
lemon now the texture mmm that's lovely
you've got that caramelized pine nuts
infused across the panna cotta really
nice but whole things fresh and fragrant
two very interesting desserts across the
board and love Prasad's little finesse
with their dessert brilliant castamere
these guys are smart which one for me
would I eat again
[Music]
- outstanding restaurants both of whom
have proved they can deliver at the
highest level
I'm about to reveal which one is worthy
of the title of my best restaurant okay
first of all well done what a night
and my god did the customers love it
tense day difficult day both restaurants
have been under immense pressure casa
mia tonight's performance
you must have balls the size of melons
to announce a risotto and not put rice
anywhere near the dish you made it out
of potatoes customers loved it
then the combination of the turbot and
the chicken wing tough to get that meat
and fish work at the same time it worked
and then the finale
not just the wow factor with the texture
of the panna cotta but that kind of
magic on top of that prasat you left the
boys standing today with the way that
you organize yourselves okra one of the
most unwanted vegetables anywhere in the
country so with a doll yeah they loved
it I know mission to star Indian
restaurants in this city that can't put
food on a plate like that well done
desserts they're never ever gonna be
everybody's cup of tea because it's like
a sweet petit four but I love the
attitude to refined it
well done
[Music]
Casa Mia you managed to excite in a way
that very few restaurants do but you're
only going to be highly successful when
your customers are with you sometimes
you step too far and you forget the
customers
prasad
Cousy your heart is bigger than any
woman's I ever known you're too generous
put more in the till yeah and stop
giving it away
okay that's been my experience from
start to finish it's been a tempestuous
journey based on everything I've
experienced taste it
witnessed
the winner and the mighty
congratulations goes to Casa Mia well
done
Kelsi
for sauce
by dying that is for you congratulations
well done
what am i done that well done Bobby well
done
Casa Mia John right Pete congratulations
well well deserves well done well done
well done well done well done well done
well done
come here well good good job good job
well done
I'm just amazed that map see it means
this is still believable
except for dream come true sir I just
soon
[Music]
my voice just pan from the condenser up
see everything I mean I've never give so
much energy in passionate of this ism or
my life history I know you're
disappointed mark I know but we have any
lost became second remember your two in
12,000 months - yeah we are disappointed
but Prasad need to grow we want to learn
more and we be going to be successful
one day I'm talking gutted for Prasad
you you've got to self-taught ladies
that cooked here tonight as if they were
cooking for their lives
that feels amazing Rashad was up against
two real thoroughbreds that are gonna
leave her a lasting impression there are
elements of that dinner tonight
that was our three-star standard between
mission starts than the wish chefs spent
25 30 years to perfect this is Hugh
because back to us what you've allied me
and Pete to do and the direction you are
vicious you color the direction in the
vision you had on kind of what me and
people want is to do with food and allow
us to do it
[Music]
so to me a sense how I should feel
since it's a mansion
yep I trust you boys
I trust you I could see the talents
[Music]
tonight's for Pacquiao and Susan was
payback nights because their sons proved
why their mom and dad have backed them
all away and tonight they Shawn I mean
they really shot cheers Oh cheers custom
here